i'm here with the luckiest man in the
world puppy ball ruff marie dan
schachner
hi dan
how are you doing we are so happy you're
here can you tell us who you brought
with you absolutely our adoptable pups
are from muddy paws rescue they're two
months old okay we got mocha venti
espresso and affogato it's a theme can
you tell us what we can expect from this
year yes so puppy bowl is in its 18th
year it's like 70 in dog years yeah
and um we have our biggest show ever
it's 118 rescue dogs our most amount of
dogs ever from across the country
from 67 shelters and 33 states
and it's really our biggest show ever we
have our kitten halftime show that's
teddy bear he's a golden doodle you're
going to have a great time watching it
today and as a referee yeah you have to
step in to talk anytime oh you do these
are untrained puppies these are not show
dogs you know so they're going to do
what puppies do
that's excessive kissing we would
actually give you a penalty for that
foul yeah that's a foul for excessive
kissing oh dan what is it that you
want people to take from
the puppy bowl adoptions aside because i
think that's the really meaningful part
what is it that we should be taking away
from the puppy ball dan other than the
obvious every one of these 118 dogs has
their own special story we have um not
just puppies like this we have special
needs dogs as well our most amount ever
we have uh siblings or most amount of
sibling pears ever but every dog has
their own story that have come to the
puppy bowl with and so they all deserve
a home by the time the puppy bowl is fun
done airing every single one of them had
been adopted oh that's amazing
and so they're all unique
and so you know you'll see dogs with uh
just three legs you'll see dogs in
wheelchairs you'll see dogs missing an
eye but we're not we're doing it just to
show you that they're as capable as any
other quote unquote able-bodied dog out
there absolutely that's amazing you
don't like the shoulders
look go long go along
there you go there you go that's a
touchdown touchdown
see it's so easy
is it like creepy if we ask um if we
could come by the puppy bowl ever and we
would be a guest of honor in fact i
could use all the help i could get so we
did have martha and snoop dogg but i
would prefer you guys next year as our
coaches oh oh we're in we are in
we will we will double down double down
and snoop we will be complimentary to
them
on team rough you guys do team fluff
okay i see what happens you really mean
that are you just throwing us a bone
i mean it
well dan thank you so much and let's do
many more things and you can watch these
adorable competitors in the puppy bowl
18 february 13th at 2pm on animal planet
and also streaming on discovery plus
i cannot thank everybody enough for
choosing to spend your time with
so us it with you
[Music]